[Musique]
la salle municipale de saint joseph
accueille le président du département de
la réunion
l'ordre du jour la réception partielle
du plan de solidarité territoriale le
pst un peu plus de 3 millions d'euros
pour booster ses projets de proximité
principalement dans deux axes c'est une
bouffée d'oxygène financière qui est
venu vers nous au moment où nous avions
bien chez un projet déjà établis après
il fallait que ça coïncide aussi avec
les objectifs du département
on a bien vu dans des travaux de
proximité la réalisation des routes et
notamment notre programme un ange notre
quartier
la réalisation d'une salle pour deux
réceptions pour les personnes âgées qui
leur soit dédiée sur le site de l'ancien
moulin rouge
l'amélioration du réseau routier et
pouvoir aussi sur quoi on a enclenché le
pacte de ce rite et de solidarité
territoriale sociale des travaux partout
cette ville du sud est clairement au
mouvement
et dans cette période de restrictions
budgétaires cette intelligence
institutionnels collective permet de
rendre le service public ville comme
saint joseph qui a connu un moment donné
pour des problèmes de circulation
aujourd'hui on le voit bien
eh bien ça va mieux les voitures
circulent mieulet les piétons 100 ans
sont plus en sécurité est le départ pour
être content d'avoir compagne et ses
efforts parce que tout cela il faut le
dire a été fait en régie communale une
visite marathon car avec plus de trente
sept mille habitants sur 178 kilomètres
carrés répartis entre mer et montagne
les problématiques ne manquent pas mais
les choses avancent selon madame boyer
en fin de réunion a dit aussi qu'elle
avait besoin d'eau à côté
eh bien ma vie
[Musique]
mais regarder autour de nous cette belle
nature là pensons aussi que rien n'est
acquis
je crois que c'est important de
raisonner si on veut parler de
citoyenneté
il y a les aménagements les équipements
il y à la partie sociale et il ya la
partie environnementale ces trois volets
fonds pour moi le socle du futur pst on
va continuer à mettre en place la
diversité de notre il nécessite de
comprendre les problématiques de chacun
le pst répond ainsi à cette solidarité
une solidarité qui a du sens